[Musique]
la santé sexuelle on a l'impression que
c'est très réducteur mais en fait c'est
très très large et si on reprend la
définition de l'OMS c'est vraiment tout
ce qui va toucher la sphère physique
mais aussi mentale affective sociale du
bien-être et du bien-être en relation
avec la vie affective relationnelle et
sexuelle
[Musique]
de faire connaître le centre de santé
sexuelle comme une ressource parce que
c'est vraiment une vraie richesse sur le
territoire pour toutes les femmes et
même pour les hommes en fait et on ne
sait pas assez et de pouvoir discuter de
sexualité d'éducation la vie sexuelle
avec Edwige qui fait plein de contenus
là-dessus qui sont super intéressants et
vraiment ça nous permet de mixer nos
regards
[Musique]
malheureusement on n'est jamais assez
sensibilisé il y a plein plein de choses
à faire et on le voit chez les jeunes on
voit un abord à la sexualité avec quand
même qui est quand même assez violent
par la pornographie et après chez les
moins jeunes en fait une fois qu'on a
passé l'âge des enfants on oublie un peu
la sexualité alors que c'est le moment
où on pourrait s'éclater quand il
commence à être un peu plus grand et
puis voilà c'est tout au long de la vie
même jusqu'à l'âge de l'EHPAD la
sexualité c'est tout le temps et donc
vraiment il y a une éducation à faire
tout le temps pour pouvoir en profiter
au maximum
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui s'éduquent
par les réseaux sociaux qui s'éduquent
par les vidéos qui voient et là l'idée
c'est de contrebalancer ça avec du
contenu de qualité et du contenu
vraiment informatif par les réseaux
sociaux voilà l'accès l'accès par les
réseaux sociaux on peut plus l'éviter
aujourd'hui les jeunes y ont accès
depuis tout petit il suffit qu'ils aient
accès à un téléphone ils arrivent à
trouver la vidéo YouTube et encore plus
vite que leurs parents dès qu'ils ont 3
ans donc on sait que ça existe on va pas
se voiler la face autant proposer par ce
biais là vraiment une information une
éducation de qualité
[Musique]